responsables de su bienestar.
Arregló caminos, mejoró los humedales,
algo de anti caza furtiva.
Y un día salimos juntos
y se encontró con las huellas de una leopardo hembra.
Y eran rastros antiguos,
pero para divertirse se volvió y comenzó a seguirlos,
y les digo, supe por la velocidad
con la que se movía por esas marcas de almohadillas,
que este hombre era un rastreador de nivel doctorado.
Si pasabas a Solly
en algún lugar fuera de la reserva,
al mirar por el retrovisor
verías que había parado el coche
20, 50 metros atrás de la carretera
por si acaso necesitabas ayuda con algo.
La única acusación que escuché hacía él
fue cuando uno de nuestros clientes dijo:
"Solly, eres patológicamente servicial".
(Risas)
Cuando empecé profesionalmente a ser guía
en este ambiente,
Solly fue mi rastreador.
Trabajamos juntos como un equipo.
Y los primeros invitados que tuvimos
fue un grupo filantrópico de la Costa Este,
y le dijeron a Solly, de lado, dijeron:
"Antes de ni siquiera salir a ver los leones y leopardos,
queremos ver dónde vives".
Así que los llevamos hasta su casa,
y esta visita de los filántropos a su casa
coincidió con un momento en que la esposa de Solly,
que estaba aprendiendo inglés,
estaba pasando por una etapa donde abría la puerta
diciendo: "Hola, te amo.
Bienvenido, te amo". (Risas)
Y había algo tan maravillosamente africano
en esto para mí, esta pequeña casa
con un gran corazón en ella.
Ahora, el día en que Solly salvó mi vida,
ya era mi héroe.
Era un día caluroso,
y nos encontramos abajo en el río.
Por del calor, me quité los zapatos,
y me enrollé los pantalones,
y caminé dentro del agua.
Solly permaneció en la ribera.
El agua era clara corriendo sobre arena,
nos desviamos y comenzamos a subir aguas arriba.
Y a pocos metros delante de nosotros,
había un lugar donde había caído un árbol de la ribera,
y sus ramas estaban tocando el agua,
y estaba sombrío.
Y si hubiera sido una película de terror,
la gente del público habría empezado a decir:
"No entres. No vayas". (Risas)
Y por supuesto, el cocodrilo estaba en las sombras.
Lo primero que ves cuando te golpea un cocodrilo
es la ferocidad de la mordedura.
¡Zas! Me di cuenta por mi pierna derecha.
Me tira. Se volteó. Lance mi mano hacia arriba, pude agarrar una rama.
Me revuelve violentamente.
Es una sensación muy extraña
tener otra criatura que quiere comerte
y hay pocas cosas que promuevan el vegetarianismo más que esa.
(Risas)
Solly en la ribera ve que tengo problemas.
Se vuelve, se aproxima hacia mí.
El cocodrilo continúa otra vez batiéndome.
Va a morder una segunda vez.
Noté una mancha de sangre en el agua alrededor mío
que se desvanecía aguas abajo.
Al morderme por segunda vez, pateo.
Mi pie va hondo en su garganta. Me escupe hacia fuera.
Me levanto agarrándome de unas ramas
y cuando salgo del agua, miro sobre mi hombro.
Mi pierna de la rodilla hacia abajo
está destrozada más allá de toda descripción.
El hueso está roto.
La carne desgarrada.
Tomé la decisión instantánea de nunca mirar eso otra vez.
Al salir del agua,
Solly llegó a una parte profunda,
un canal entre nosotros.
Él sabe, ve el estado de mi pierna,
sabe que entre él y yo
hay un cocodrilo,
y puedo decir que este hombre no paró ni un segundo.
Entró directamente en el canal.
Se hundió arriba de su cintura.
Llegó a mí. Me agarró.
Todavía estoy en una posición vulnerable.
Me carga y me pone sobre sus hombros.
Esta es otra cosa sobre Solly, es monstruosamente fuerte.
Se vuelve. Me saca a la ribera.
Me pone en el suelo. Se quita su camisa.
La envuelve alrededor de mi pierna,
me carga por segunda vez,
me lleva a un vehículo,
y es capaz de conseguirme atención médica.
Y sobreviví.
Ahora —aplausos—
Ahora no sé cuánta gente conocen
capaz de entrar en un canal profundo de agua
que saben que hay un cocodrilo
para ir en su ayuda,
pero para Solly, era tan natural como respirar.
Y es un ejemplo sorprendente
de lo que he experimentado por toda el África.
En una sociedad más colectiva,
nos damos cuenta desde el interior
que nuestro bienestar está profundamente ligado
al bienestar de los demás.
Se comparte el peligro. Se comparte el dolor.
Se comparte la alegría. Se comparte el logro.
Se comparten las casas. Se comparte la comida.
Ubuntu nos pide que abramos nuestros corazones
y compartamos,
y lo que me enseñó Solly ese día
es la esencia de este valor,
su acción animada, empática
en cada momento.
Ahora aunque la raíz de la palabra es sobre la gente,
pensé que tal vez ubuntu era solo sobre la gente.
Y entonces conocí a esta joven.
Su nombre era Elvis.
De hecho, Solly le dio el nombre de Elvis
porque dijo que caminaba como hacía
Elvis el baile de la pelvis.
Nació con patas traseras y la pelvis seriamente deformadas.
Llegó a nuestra reserva de una reserva
al este de la nuestra en su ruta migratoria.
Cuando la vi por primera vez,
pensé que moriría en cuestión de días.
Y sin embargo, en los 5 años siguientes
regresaba en los meses de invierno.
Y nos emocionaríamos mucho de estar fuera en la selva
y encontrar esta pista inusual.
Parecía un soporte invertido,
y pararíamos lo que estuviéramos haciendo y la seguiríamos,
y luego llegaríamos a la vuelta de la esquina,
y ahí estaría con su manada.
Y ese torrente de emociones
de las personas en nuestros camiones safari
al verla, fue este sentido de afinidad.
Y me recordó
que incluso las personas que crecen en las ciudades
sienten una conexión natural
con el mundo natural y con los animales.
Y aún sigo sorprendido de que ella haya sobrevivido.
Un día llegamos a ellos en este pequeño abrevadero.
Era una especie de hueco en el suelo.
Y observé como la matriarca bebió,
y luego volvió con ese hermoso movimiento lento de los elefantes,
que parece como un brazo en movimiento,
y ella comenzó ir hasta el borde escarpado.
El resto de la manada se volvió y comenzó a seguir.
Y vi a la joven Elvis
comenzar a ponerse nerviosa por subir la colina.
Era visible, las orejas hacia adelante,
tenía que subir y estaba a mitad de camino,
sus piernas cedieron y cayó hacia atrás.
Lo intentó una segunda vez,
y una vez más, a medio camino, cayó de espaldas.
Y en el tercer intento,
algo increíble sucedió.
A mitad de camino hasta la ribera,
un elefante joven adolescente vino detrás de ella,
y apoyó su tronco debajo de ella,
y empezó a sacarla hacia la ribera.
Y se me ocurrió
que el resto de la manada
de hecho estaba cuidando esta elefante joven.
Al día siguiente vi otra vez
como la matriarca rompió una rama
y se lo puso en su boca,
y luego rompió una segunda
y la puso en el suelo.
Y un consenso de todos nosotros
los que guiamos personas en esa zona
es que esa manada de hecho se movía despacio
para dar cabida a esa elefante.
Lo que Elvis y la manada me enseñaron
me llevó a ampliar mi definición de ubuntu,
y creo que en la catedral de la naturaleza,
vamos a ver las partes más hermosas de nosotros mismos
reflejadas hacia nosotros.
Y no es solo a través de otras personas
que podamos experimentar nuestra humanidad
sino a través de todas las criaturas que viven en este planeta.
Si África tiene un don para compartir,
es el regalo de una sociedad más colectiva.
Y si bien es cierto que ubuntu es una idea africana,
lo que veo es la esencia de ese valor
que se inventó aquí.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Pat Mitchell: Boyd,
sabemos que tú conociste al presidente Mandela
en tu primera infancia
y que oíste la noticia como todos lo hicimos hoy,
y que te afecta profundamente
y sabemos la trágica pérdida que es para el mundo.
Pero me preguntaba si quisieras
compartir algún pensamiento adicional,
porque sabemos que oíste la noticia
justo antes de venir a esta sesión.
Boyd Varty: Bueno gracias, Pat.
Estoy muy feliz porque ya era hora de que él descansara.
Estaba sufriendo.
Y por supuesto hay emociones mezcladas.
Pero pienso en tantas ocurrencias
como cuando fue al show de Oprah
y le preguntó que sobre que sería el programa.
(Risas)
Y era como, "Bueno, será sobre Usted".
Es decir, es simplemente una increíble humildad.
(Risas)
Él fue el padre de nuestra nación
y tenemos un camino por recorrer en Sudáfrica.
Y todo, solían llamarle la magia Madiba.
Saben, solía ir a un partido de rugby y ganaríamos.
A cualquier lugar que fuera, las cosas salían bien.
Pero creo que la magia estará con nosotros,
y lo importante es que llevamos
lo que él representaba.
Y eso es lo que voy a intentar y hacer,
y eso es lo que intentan hacer personas en toda Sudáfrica.
PM: Y eso es lo que has hecho hoy. BV: Gracias.
PM: Gracias. BV: Gracias. Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)